Gina Rodriguez is opening up to ET about
her newest passion project movement
Monday's Latinos make a splash in the
box office and Latinos can do that in a
heartbeat so it's really nice to empower
the Latino actors and directors and just
to you know send the message that
there's a lot of wonderful positive
things going on in our community and
that's what we should focus on each
Monday the Jane the Virgin star is
highlighting members of the Latino
community who have major impact on their
fields and she wants others to do the
same it's me doing it for my you know
like to uplift and highlight and empower
other Latinos so anybody that's like a
party social media like champion
champion the people around you champion
somebody that we don't know about so far
gina has put the social media spotlight
on big names like Eva Longoria and Oscar
Isaac but she's also focusing on those
behind the camera like Robert Rodriguez
at first I was definitely trying to give
information to Latino community I think
and the more I do this two more
information and education will be given
out in our power and what we can do as a
community if we unite together and start
using our power for good check out
Gina's Instagram each Monday to see her
latest inspiring post about the Latino
community move in Monday's young lad it
was dead
you